but i find myself thinking hey listen
this is cool i just raised 80 million
dollars and i'm spending a night
with the homeless people like an open
person in the train station penn station
baltimore and that just keeps you humble
you know that kind of stuff just makes
you remember listen man this hasn't
changed the seven years have been a
fantastic ride but the grind the hustle
it's still there and i have pictures
from there and i used to show them to
people because i think it's nice you
know how god keeps you humble how he
says yeah man if you think you guys are
doing good if you think you're rich just
remember i can flip anything in a second
right so never forget where you came
from never forget who you are never
forget where you're going
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
i'm so excited for this episode please
meet ift kirzner the co-founder and
active president since 2015 of kistera
if he's passionate about business
innovation and people he is a skilled
tech entrepreneur for the majority of
his career he invested in founding and
managing several companies focused on
financial services and data management
prior to his business career ift was a
successful israeli entertainer known for
his music and tv show which i followed
closely ift holds an llb degree with
distinction and masters degree in
political science and he is a graduate
of the lyndon b johnson school of public
affairs leadership program meet ifti
[Music]
i have to say that i'm actually kind of
used to to talking to you like this it
used to be one-sided i used to i i was a
big you know i would say ladies fan and
so i obviously used to to watch you on
on the television screen except then i
would talk but but you didn't respond
but but now you are responding so now i
get to to actually have a conversation
but but you know your life
i was responding to all the millions of
kids that were struggling on the tv i
could hear you you know doing the wrong
stuff saying the wrong things i was the
kind of guy that was always kind of
goofy and geeky and i was i heard
everybody i was trying to implement it
to the way i hosted you know my show
but thank you for bringing that up it
was it was an amazing kind of period of
time in my life probably the best job i
ever had i mean hosting a tv show for
kids giving away prizes and bicycles and
everything you know why you know getting
to meet all the biggest celebrities in
israel and the singers and the artists
and now i you know i know i'm in high
tech and selling insurance in the united
states so i don't really know how my
life got to this point maybe this isn't
what the conversation is about but now
we're here today talking about you know
high tech and start up and all that kind
of stuff which i cannot say anything bad
about i mean it's great and it's
interesting it's not like hosting your
tv show you know and your own show
everything live in front of millions of
people but you know everything and it's
time and its place and course in life
and i'm doing this but i'm just kidding
set aside this is a uh you know uh a
show about about high tech and
entrepreneurship which is which is
fantastic and by the way i see a lot of
similarities between that between what i
did not that you have the question but
you know what i did for the first dream
of my life was you know talking to
people and making people have a good
time and when you think about what i'm
trying to do today i kistera and we'll
get in this second to what we do is more
important than anything else make sure
that people enjoy their time there and
have a good time forget about the fact
that every sunday i i run my own kind of
half hour hour show in front of the
whole company and we give prizes and we
do stuff but it's just the fact that the
atmosphere is so important you know
we're 70 people strong now we're a
growing company and i feel like the
energy the vibes not to get
too much into this whole kind of new age
stuff but the energy and the vibes in
the office and in the company
internationally is so important to me so
for the last what is it
17 years i've been doing the same thing
trying to have fun trying to have the
people around me you know have fun
enjoying themselves just now we're doing
this under the excuse of a company if
you go to the castero website it says
there you know you know black on white
we're just a bunch of kids that are
trying to have fun and trying to run a
company and do our best and yeah i'm
saying do you have a question because i
can go i can go on for 20 minutes just
talking about that but sorry great to be
here
yeah i i like what you're used to that i
mean i'm the host now i get to now host
you and uh that's right and that's why i
stopped brother it's all you
you know this show is about high tech
and entrepreneurship but but more
importantly it's about leadership and
it's about what what makes for a leader
and and how do people experience life
and in unique ways that position them
in these really interesting places in
life where they have some they have this
i this understanding that a lot of
others maybe don't because of these
unique experiences and so while i do
want us to get to to kistera and and
it's it's a phenomenally fast growing
company but first i want to understand
you better and i do want to dive deeper
into
what you did as a television host
because i i do want to paint the picture
because there's a lot of television
shows around the world what's unique
about a woodside lady and the show that
you hosted
was that we had this very unique
situation in which literally every kid
in israel
would come home and watch this show
it wasn't you know you know if portion
of people that that know this this was
the life of kids
everybody watch it listen i grew up on
it you grew up i mean we all grew up in
it and i was just fortunate enough in a
period of time in my life for you know
for three years to be there as a host of
of the show and
i think it all comes together in
into believing in yourself right i think
i think entrepreneurship i think that
the career that i had and as a tv host
and i was a musician before that it's
all about enjoying yourself and
believing in yourself and trying to go
through a path with something that you
actually believe in listen i never
planned to be a host of i would send a
demo you call it the children's channel
right israel's children channel it's
something that happened to me and it's
funny because i have people that they
talk to me and they're like yeah this
was my dream my whole life and since i
was a kid i always dreamt to be a host
on this show it wasn't a dream for me it
was more like just how life became i
came up from an entrepreneurial house
right and i talk about that a lot in
interviews because i think it's really
important having somebody in your
household that believes in you whether
it's your father your mother your
siblings
you really have to grow from a sense of
that right and i know it's the same with
you right you're a very successful dad
it kind of you get nurtured into that
kind of lifestyle but besides all the
entrepreneurship it was just believing
yourself in anything you know when i was
17 i came up to my mom and i said hey
mom i'm gonna have a number one song on
the radio and she looked at me and she
was like hey honey listen i love you and
you're talented but but you don't know
how to sing or play any instrument how
are you going to have a number one song
on the radio and i was like listen mom i
think i figured out something about
human beings about how they think about
what's important about you know how i
think i can figure this out she was like
you know what son
go get it you know they supported me and
then they provided me with like with the
initial funding i needed to go you know
to drive all the way to tel aviv and
start recording stuff that they really
believed in me i had no musical
education i could not sing i can't play
the instrument my mom and my dad were
very supportive and lucky for some
reason if you're so confident this you
can go do that and then you know in my
very you know early 20s and late teens i
had some very successful musical songs i
don't know if you're familiar with them
sorry for speaking hebrew some you know
you know very big songs in israel they
all came from that belief of you know
what i'm thinking i think i'm on to
something and i'm willing to put myself
on the line to test it right i'm willing
to humiliate myself and actually putting
myself out there because think about
that that's the truth in starting
something right it doesn't matter if
it's a company or a tv show or or being
a musician it believes in putting
yourself out there putting yourself out
there to be judged by other people to
actually do not to be the kind of people
that stay on the stands and just look at
other people's doing but get on the
playing field try you know give it your
best shot i'm a big believer in that and
that's what i did yeah and
you know
yeah sorry
you're you're making i have to say you
know i agree with everything you're
saying but
here you are you're saying listen i i
wanted to i never wanted to be a
television host and here i was you know
one of the most popular hosts in in
israel where literally every kid on the
street recognizes me i didn't really
have any musical background but hey i
made it to the top song on the radio
with some phenomenal songs and then i
went on to be a co-founder and president
of this hyper growth startup in the tech
scene that has nothing to do with with
television or entertainment
it can't be that it happened to be that
just everything worked out perfectly
it's not possible
let's listen when i hear it from you it
sounds like a wild story and and it has
been you know a wild 18 years and i've
been very eclectic right i've been all
over the place like he said i i
fortunately right i was very fortunate
and god blessed me to be successful as a
musician to be successful as an
entertainer you know as a tv host and
not to be successful as a company owner
and founder co-founder uh with my
amazing partner sega chilton but
i think it's more about
believing yourself and putting in the
hours right let's not sugarcoat this i'm
i'm i've been grinding for the last 17
years of my life man grinding like i
don't care about anything i've i've i've
unfortunately lost connection with my
friends i can hardly see my family i've
been on the crime right that's not
trying to paint the picture like
everything works perfectly it works
perfectly because thank god i think i'm
talented enough i had enough belief my
surrounding had belief in me and i put
in part my french to effing time
put in the time put in the effort i hate
this stupid 2022 shortcut kind of thing
you know those kids they make millions
off tick tock you know them i hate them
i'm sorry i'm saying this live you know
they spend like i don't know an hour a
day they're millionaires
oh my god guys i hate you i have to work
at 18 hours a day to make money right
and you guys are like
unwrapping
gifts from or playing playstation on
twitch and making millions i hate you
guys and if i could curse out curse but
also all what i've been taught in my
family is hustle wake up go hustle take
that bus take that train take that plane
fly overseas i'm talking to you in an
hour i'm going to the airport i haven't
even packed look at my my place looks
like a mess man i'm i'm moving but my
it's a messy life right i just came back
two to two weeks ago from from san
francisco i'm flying tomorrow tonight to
chicago i'm flying to nashville next
week it's a mess i don't know what time
zone i'm in i don't know what hour it is
i don't know if my wife is gonna is
awake or go to sleep i don't know if my
son recognizes me listen i can talk only
about it it's a mess right
but but but but
i was fortunate enough
to be successful i cannot even imagine
what would happen if i would have gone
through all this mess but i wasn't also
successful right because think about
most people you know they put in the
effort man they put in the effort not
everyone is successful just
statistically speaking right so you also
need to be lucky you need god to shine
his love on you right not to sound too
preachy but you also need god to shout
to shine his light on you but he's not
going to do it if you're just sitting at
home you know what i take it back if
you're a good uh what is it called
fortnite player and people are willing
to pay you on twitch millions of dollars
to you know to play playstation then god
tempt you in a different way but the way
he touched me is he woke me up in the
morning and he said ifp you better go to
work son you better go to work and you
know
we were last year we were bootstrapped
because they're all
talk just a little bit about what we are
who what we do we're we're an insurance
company where the world's first uh
insurance marketing operating system we
help insurance carriers in the us mostly
auto insurance carriers uh run effective
and profitable marketing campaigns
digital marketing and distribution so
it's billions of dollars and we help
them do that i'll stop talking about
insurance because i don't want to get to
do but if that interests somebody reach
out to us like sarah will help you you
know run
profitable marketing distribution but my
point was that we were bootstrapped for
six and a half years so a year ago uh we
did our first trial around a 76 million
dollars from manoa
uh two of the you know largest financial
institutions in israel one of the
largest round a's in israel's history
for you know from these kind of
institutions for uh
uh this kind of startup company and we
were very lucky to have that but
we still
grind right i still fly in hours that
are not hours to places that are not
places and i take buses and i take
trains and i holler calves off the
street to get the points and i would
drive from boston to new york and back
in the night to get to at 8 am you know
meeting so you got to do that right i
would sleep that's what i did a couple
months ago was a little bit colder
outside i missed the flight because you
know when it gets really cold on the
east coast they cancel flights all the
time right uh washington new york uh
boston they cancel flights all the time
because of the weather so i had i i
finished some meetings in in texas and i
had to fly out to
new york for some other meetings and my
flight can't get getting cancelled right
you have an 8 p.m flight and they pinged
you like 45 minutes being before oh now
you don't have flight you're trying to
get another flight you're at the end at
the airport they're like oh this flight
gets delayed you get delayed demand
delay debates at like 2 3 4 a.m like i
have to get to new york right so you
catch a fight to sell my kind of flight
to washington from washington i took an
uber to baltimore i had to spend the
night in penn station in baltimore now i
don't know if you've ever been to penn
station in baltimore let alone spend the
night i don't want to get too
descriptive about what that place looks
like right but i find myself thinking
hey listen this is cool i just raised 80
million dollars and i'm spending a night
with the homeless people like an open
person in the train station penn station
baltimore and that just keeps you humble
you know that kind of stuff just makes
you remember listen man this hasn't
changed the seven years have been a
fantastic ride but the grind the hustle
it's still there and i have pictures
from there and i think to show them to
people because i think it's nice you
know how god keeps you humble how he
says yeah man if you think you guys are
doing good if you think you're rich just
remember i can flip anything in a second
right so never forget it where you came
from never forget who you are never
forget where you're going don't become
this posh private plane kind of show
further kind of waving with my name at
the airport well i have nothing against
people do that right good for them my
hat's off to them i'm not like that
i don't know how to become that right
i'm the same guy i used to catch buses
in tel aviv you know 17 years ago to
record my first album now i'm doing that
trying to secure you know partnerships
with the largest insurance carriers in
the world in the united states but the
mindset that mindset of you know attack
go go get it man nobody's going to get
it for you uh i think is super important
in in leadership in entrepreneurship and
it really helps people follow you if you
want to talk about leadership i think
you need to lead by example i think it's
people see you putting in the time
putting in the effort doing what's
necessary it really helps people you
know relate to you relate to the cause
and and just feel better about you know
taking part of this so so i i thank
everybody you know on our team like i
said 70 people strong which is
mind-boggling and phenomenal and crazy
and and and you can see my mindset just
from this short conversation i'm i'm out
there right i'm sporadic with my
thoughts i can keep talking about
everything so this is how i work too i
worked very high intense very high
energy very good we'll go let's do it
and i love it because that's the only
way i feel like i can work so if you
want to bring it back to you know what i
came up with which was you know the
entertainment industry this is what
we're doing man we're trying to keep the
conversation entertaining we're trying
to keep people entertained and it
doesn't matter if it's you on you know
on your show or it doesn't matter if
it's an insurance executive in in you
know somewhere in the united states it
doesn't doesn't matter if it's in
investors from this private equity or vc
right keep the people entertained
because we're trying to have a good time
it's just money it's just technology
it's just insurance for us don't take
yourselves too seriously right my
instagram literally says that my bio
says don't take yourself too seriously
and i just got my verified check mark on
instagram so if anybody's watching this
i'm ift.kersner
on instagram follow me i don't have
enough followers i need some more
followers oh but yeah i'm trying to i'm
going to get some content so i just
plugged my instagram so yeah
[Music]
theme is hustling and grinding i think
what you're talking about and i share a
lot of the same frustrations and the
and i share the same i think a lot
of the same mindset as you share which
is this idea that at the end you know
it's all about hard work and you know at
the end where we're seeing all these
magical stories of you know overnight
successes none of that exists you're
grinding for 17 years we didn't
you're mentioning you know some of these
things that are that are not easy to
comprehend you know whether it be family
friends your own lifestyle i mean this
is what some of the hardest things that
any person can endure but you're finding
the fulfillment by being yourself and by
by being that being able to balance them
and i think by the way just to touch on
this generation z in 2022 part of the
issue is that we're seeing these
overnight successes we're seeing these
overnight millionaires well for every
fortnight millionaire that's playing you
know we have millions of other players
who think they'll make it just by
playing but you know but they're they
why why aren't i successful
and and
about entertainment really it's about
curiosity right it's about how do i get
the other person to really listen to me
and to form a conversation
they're engaged right this is what it's
all about right
now so i said listen
i don't want to i don't want to
sugarcoat this right
i work
in a tech company
that that built a core platform for
insurance cameras right it's not the
most sexy thing in the world right let's
be honest it's not like people wake up
in the morning oh my god i have
technology for insurance right and we go
all through and we're a data company so
it's not only about that but we dive
into the data and we dive into the
diagnostics and we dive into we crunch
the numbers a day in and day out so the
way you make it interesting the way you
make it engaging is caring it's doing it
your way it's doing it different right i
actually care about my partners i don't
see them as wallets paying me money
i see them as people trying to provide
for their families just like i'm trying
to provide for my family that puts us on
a mission together that and not lose our
minds while doing so right so we're on
the same mission they're trying to do
their best job i'm trying to do my best
job together we're collaborating so
that's what makes it engaged right i
don't want to go on your show and start
pitching my my stuff like like i'm
boring oh yeah sign up to gastera go to
getster.com and we have the best
technology and ai and machine learning
and data science right everybody's
talking about that you have to say i
know i i want to go through a
conversation without saying ai if i
didn't just say you know jokingly this
has nothing to do with what i'm trying
to sell i'm trying to sell good people
doing a good job and if somebody can
relate to that then yes the ai the
machine learning the data science that's
all going to come constructed upon that
but let's start as we are as people can
we relate to each other do we have a
common ground do we have common beliefs
because if not our partnership is not
going to be that prosperous from from my
kind of perspective and also
it's just boring man it's i mean i'm
really
you're smarter than me man you're a
stanford you can handle these
conversations better than me i i would
get bored man i can if there's not fun
in it if there's no pizzazz if you don't
spice it up a little bit it would become
impossible so you try to you try to do
your way you try to do the good way you
try to do the positive way and good
things happen and you know how i know
because i'm living proof of that man
i'm living proof i don't i knew nothing
about music i knew nothing about tv and
i knew nothing about insurance or
technology before opening this company
literally i did not know i did not grow
up from that right did not come from
that all i grew up with was the mindset
of
hey let's do this man yeah let's go
let's we can if somebody can do it we
can do it let's put in the time let's
put in the effort let's let's get around
this you know a bunch of group of
talented people which another point i
just want i don't know if we have enough
time i just want to say something that
is really important good
people i know it's cliche i know it
sounds cheesy i do not know how to do
anything by myself for the last 17 years
i've been blessed by working with great
people from great musicians that that
helped me you know orchestrate and
record my stuff because i can't play any
instrument so they helped me with that
all the way to great people on you know
from from from the television industry
of you know whispering in my ear what's
the name of the next guest what's the
name of the song because i can't
remember anything so having great people
in control all the way to the amazing
amazing team that we have at kistera
that's really it's a company built of
its people so i think my talent was
gathering
the smartest best nicest kindest people
around me starting with my partner sega
chilton who is the smartest person i
know in the world hands down he is a
genius like you you guys need to talk to
each other on a different call for when
the geniuses talk uh for me it's about
you know having him and assembling
really group of people that that are
talented and that care you know our
company really cares when you come visit
our office and i hope when when you're
you know back in israel visiting you
come visit us in tel aviv
you know it doesn't look like every
other office we care about stuff we care
about each other we care about the
positive and kindness actual as actual
course and i think like i said my life
is living proof that if you're constant
with that and if you have you know
enough talent a big talent then then you
can really do whatever whatever you want
to and once again circling that back up
to leadership
be a positive leader man be a positive
leader you know when i leave i have this
white board which i write messages to my
company when i fly you know abroad it's
never reach your
goals you know sell the software how
much money are we making no it's always
enjoy your week you know have fun be
kind to each other go do something
interesting eat healthy drink healthy be
you know don't worry on your diet just
felt like random stuff that keeps you
focused and i don't even want to start
about dieting because traveling and
entrepreneurship is the worst thing for
your diet in the world i usually have a
timer you know in t i need to when you
speak at conferences or a tv show you
have a timer so you know how much you
can talk so i just understood that when
i talk without a timer i can go on
talking for like 40 minutes because i
have i need something to actually stop
it so i'll stop again well the you know
the benefit that you have is that you're
interesting and that you're exciting and
and and i'm super engaged and and i love
this and so
it would be much worse if you didn't
have a timer you didn't know how to do
it and you were boring as well so that
combination would be devastating but you
know
to to to reflect on what you're saying
at the end the i'm taking this this word
boring and entertainment and and good
people and i'm distilling it to this
idea of you know let's let's remember
what we're why we're doing what we're
doing right we're not here to make money
we're not here to just sell to sell
software or to just build products we're
here to actually live our life it's as
simple as that we're each here we're
living our life we're living our life in
in pretty similar ways you know most
most people around us and if we're able
to find this common ground those common
shared values that that that are
together maybe in our in most of our
conversations we don't have to go head
to head we can actually start crossing
arms and say okay what like is this a
partnership that we actually want to
have and if so how do we make it a
win-win situation for all of us and then
we'll have a great time doing so whether
it's company
people or insurance partners or
television hosts or kids on the show or
people listening to the music
that is a hundred percent accurate but
listen i don't want to act like a thing
so i want to explain something
when we opened the company it was about
money and it says so with my website
we're not running from that right
uh of course
we weren't looking to change the world
we weren't looking to change the
insurance industry we were looking to
get rich i'm trying to be honest because
when you don't have money what you're
looking for is money right when you're
when when you don't have
exactly when you don't have enough to
buy a house to buy a car to buy whatever
you need for yourself then you you're
looking to get paid right so to be
honest the first couple of years it was
about making money and we were laser
focused only after we were fortunate
enough to make money then we said you
know what
maybe we can change the world maybe now
that we have enough we're actually in a
better position to refocus ourselves on
really creating impact and really
creating that environment because if
somebody said that he thought so from
the beginning i'm sorry to say he might
be a liar when you're starving you're
not thinking about making the world a
better place you're thinking about
feeding yourself right so i was thinking
about feeding myself but when i became
comfortable with what i had only then i
could honestly start looking outwards
right and saying okay now i have enough
how do i make all my employees all of
our employees rich right how do we make
everybody work in this company have a
better lives like i was fortunate to
have but i believe that to say it from a
real honest place you have to be doing
well for yourself as well right you have
to take care of number one because once
you do that you're in a confident enough
position to say i can now spread the
love i can help spread the wealth
because i'm comfortable right i'm not
saying i'm you know be elon musk i'm
saying put yourself in a position where
you're comfortable when you can take
care of your family and then that really
grounds you and gives you the ability to
look at the other and really be a better
person you know externally that's what
that's from my personal experience and
that that's what i believe in
ift
thank you very much this was awesome
we'll continue in person this was
amazing
thank you brother
we'll see you when you come visit and
we'll see you soon thank you everybody
thank you
you